apparently
Joe
by the way credit like we've been giving
them has been on a roll really lately
with like [ __ ] Mark [ __ ]
Zuckerberg and Alex Barrison like the
people's been getting on have been
actually pretty Aaron Rodgers he's been
getting really good people on
so we knew the street couldn't continue
this is him talking about Andrew Tate
being the platformed I won't ruin who's
in the video for you guys watching but
it's fun okay it's it's definitely a
star-studded uh video yeah you on
Instagram
in the post today to let everybody know
the fight companion the shadow band and
then there's Eddie Bass foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
stop
I'm not even trying to joke with you
anymore you need to stop for your own
good
stop
all her people they won't allow me to
follow anybody
I like Getty Bravo so
he's weird he's a [ __ ] weird dude but
I like him he's definitely a weird guy
but I like him
students to think I'm a dick
I'm like I'm trying to follow you well
maybe I'm trying to make mail I like
that they have Brian Callan in the New
York Times Out Chair
yes the New York Times out yeah that's
where you have to say I think a little
dunce cap on them
chair whenever there's a wrestler yeah
exactly exactly it's that's a c for the
person that's actually going to
interview The Undertaker yes
I do screenshot video I got look look
boom and I go back look it says follow
now you're following then I go off the
page and I go back follow back I press
it and I go off the page and then I go
look it keeps going back to follow back
maybe don't call it a scandemic etc
they're gonna round
hey um
CIA Callan
why don't you not tell me anybody what
to do with their lives okay maybe don't
[ __ ] accuse one of your friends of an
international hacking crime
before you start talking about people
calling it a scandemic
follow back I press it and I go off the
page and then I go look it keeps going
back to follow back maybe don't call it
a scandemic etc they're going to arouse
the the powers that be why can't by the
way notice that nobody took Collins back
there did you notice he's he's he really
is trying to earn his way back into the
group you can see it right I'm not the
only one seeing that the dynamic has
kind of changed a little bit like when
that when Callan and Schwab used to come
on Callan was would be would be in the
dominant chair
and now he's been relegated to the you
know like the New York Times Out Chair
they sent me
they warned me somebody likes you there
because at least you're not Andrew Kate
things about women that P was saying
that like what what did he say that
specifically got them triggered because
it was basically saying massaging look
he plays part of it is like a character
and part of it he's a legit world
champion kickboxer who's a hard man so
let's tell these guys who who doesn't
Brennan
notice how nobody interrupted anybody
else when they were talking
because
he's a heart that's what I was telling
him tell him
jokes do I tell him Joe
didn't buy any [ __ ] [ __ ] and and
that's what's resonating with young
people and he's also a pro-trump the
worry is that he's going to the kids are
going to listen to him because he's he's
big on Tick Tock my 12 year old and my
14 year old asked me about Andrew Tate
I said he's a legit world champion
kickboxer I like him a lot why do you
like him and I was asking him they said
he says a lot of funny stuff on on
Twitter and Tick Tock it's the tick tock
thing because the tick tock algorithm he
did something where he started something
where you like join his group yes and
then you're supposed to like post stuff
it's brilliant that's how he gets
followers and but also gives you a page
he blew up yes is he describing a forum
Rogan used to have one
I think rookie just described an
internet Forum yeah that's the message
it's this thing where you could post
stuff and interact with other people
the internet
because he's a brilliant man yeah my
thing is with the left I mean
I like Andrew Tate and that he told the
system to go [ __ ] themselves
I also do believe I do agree with Rogan
I do believe half of Andrew more than
half of Tate's thing is is a character
and I don't begrudge people for playing
characters like that because if it
[ __ ] works it works right
but
he's not a brilliant man okay and and
I'm not [ __ ] on him he should have
been banned we're Rumble family now
Rumble gang gang however
brilliant is a little bit basically and
I've said this before there was an
Andrew Tate every five to ten years we
have a new Andrew Tate Hunter Moore was
the one before him right Tucker Max
Tucker Max and mystery remember the
pickup artist like there's always been
these people
brilliant I don't know great marketer
[ __ ] Absolutely I'll give him all the
credit in the world for that
and anyone that pisses Ethan Klein off
is okay in my book to be honest with you
amen that's all it takes for me you
pissy incline off yeah I like you man
whatever
so I mean you know take them away and
they're like we should look up to that
okay then who should we look up to
well Brendan I'm probably not you
I'll nominate myself
Jesus Christ why is he dressing like
he's [ __ ] gonna be in a movie with
Sammy the bull what are you gonna run
numbers Brendan what the [ __ ] man
not their job to just say hey this guy's
a danger to young men what are you
talking about like his what a lot of
times he was talking about how he says
become a high value person man or woman
and don't [ __ ] with people who will be
low low quality [ __ ] up with the
misogynist yes because if he didn't do
that if he just said the pro mail stuff
yeah he's been all right and you know
Pro
this is what happens though
what they just said it's capitulating
right he shouldn't have said the
misogynistics
why
because I'm sorry do do these people
Joe and I've been liking to draw a lot
lately so I'm not even [ __ ] but Joe
still thinks that we are in like 2014
sometimes where he thinks that
if Andrew Tata just played the game
doing that he would he still would have
been banned guys
before he said the misogynistic stuff
Joe they were accusing him Ethan Klein
just said it the other day they were
accusing him of being a sex trafficker I
don't think that him making Al Bundy
jokes was the reason he was popped they
were going to take him out anyway this
wasn't because of that it didn't help
him I'll give you that but come on man
no accountability and pro discipline
stuff and you know he was supposed to go
yeah but if you did that and by the way
Joe if you don't need the pro
accountability and discipline stuff then
you wouldn't be talking about him now
and nobody would and he'd be every other
one of those guys in the manosphere you
know yeah he would just be another guy
in the manosphere picking up hookers in
Colombia pretending he's a pickup artist
you know what I mean
but now he's part of the rumble fam
Rumble fam Rumble gang gang
the way I think in the morning the how I
feel has no bearing on what I do he goes
I do everything I'm supposed to do he
goes like get up he goes if I don't feel
good I still work out of course he goes
I still work I still go I do everything
I'm supposed to do because that's that's
how you get ahead in this life if you
just concentrate entirely on your
feelings you're never gonna [ __ ] get
anywhere exactly no hey no Brendan he's
speaking specifically to you
if you keep concentrating only on your
feelings you're never going to get
anywhere Brendan he's speaking to you
true and that's a good lesson for people
to learn the problem is another [ __ ] the
other like there's a video of him
I don't know what what the context of
the video is he's like in that girl no
that was consensual and and by the way
what was it she came out and said they
were both kind of weird calm down Brian
kind of weird what a super fan Brian
Callan is though right did you I didn't
know he's gonna be such a super fan into
this role-playing [ __ ] so both of them
she came out and she was like that's
what we're into out of context so like
I'll be honest we're doing a companion I
didn't see it and it just came out me
and Bert watched I was like Jesus Christ
what is he doing we didn't have contacts
I'm like that ain't good man he's [ __ ]
we didn't have context so we jumped to
conclusions
to jump to conclusions man everybody in
this room except for Brian I can't
believe I'm just gonna say this oh any
problem doesn't say anything but
everyone the other three two people in
this room in this conversation
all started with saying I have no
context but here's my opinion on it
um
and then the other guy is Brian Callan
but then once you realize she was she
comes out and she's like no hold on
that's what we're into that we both
agreed to that it's like well to each
their own that's what you want to do
right why is that I don't agree with you
doing comedy but I mean you should be
allowed to do it Brendan
I mean
there's all these videos that I've
laughed my ass off at dudes ball gagged
like CEOs I've not seen tied behind
their back Hey Joe
why have you seen those videos
for a goof just to laugh did it sound
like he just said I don't know man hold
on that's what we're into that we both
agreed let me hear that again well to
each their own that's what you want to
do right why is that bad but there's all
these videos that I've laughed my ass
off at dudes ball gagged like CEOs I'm
not tied behind their back yet we're
getting their nuts yeah their nuts
kicked yeah that's okay that's something
hey guys
um
what kind of videos you guys watching
here is is that
do you guys watch that well yeah we like
we watched like [ __ ] and ball torture no
with our homies well you don't watch
that I like lesbian stuff mostly let's
send your homies videos are you jerking
off and stuff like normal normal MMA
fight guy stuff oh man I jerk off and
then I have shame afterwards like a
normal guy what are you doing what are
you watching this is typical Jujitsu
stuff man hey are you the guy that's
past the ball gang in his mouth and
you're pretending it's a video to like
see feel the room out you ever do that
you ever see when someone tries to feel
the room yeah yeah are you the ball
talking ball torture guy are you trying
are you trying to feel the room out
like man [ __ ] and ball torch that [ __ ]
is [ __ ] weird right like Lou would be
into that kind of thing all right anyone
and also I mean
kalai was like yeah and like intra
incest porch should be more mainstream
right guys high five
guys
Rob anybody
um